bonjour à tous j'ai parlé du cs avec
[Musique]
si vous suivez mes vidéos il vous aura
pas échappé que je suis parti aux crs à
las vegas il ya quelques temps forcément
tourner beaucoup parler tu publié
beaucoup de vidéos j'en ai encore plein
sous le coude
donc on va continuer à en parler dans
les temps à venir mais justement le crs
j'en ai parlé avec avec le président de
la république qui est la voie la petite
balade avec emmanuel macron bien sûr
donc fort sympathique
[Musique]
j'étais aux crs le jour quelques jours
et j'ai pensé au concept il ya deux ans
et la salle j ja c'est exactement ça et
langue ça vaut pas vraiment la prensa
que des présents sur une valeur comme je
les envie de la france et on voit qu'à
vraiment les moyens
des volontés en tout cas du l'économie
de la france de pousser ce que la paire
française penser une rencontre de ouf
rencontré le président de la république
lui parler du cs de la french tech de
l'ensemble des start up de la présence
française des startups à l'international
de la force de frappe de la france
pouvoir parler directement avec le
président de la république avec emmanuel
macron c'est inconcevable c'était
complètement inconcevable alors je vais
vous raconter parce que j'ai eu la
chance d'aller au cs en étant
accréditées par business france la
french touch
je sais pas si vous suivez beaucoup ma
chaise mais je parle bien évidemment de
sujets très grand public parce que ça
m'intéresse
bien évidemment les problématiques
autour des smartphones de notre
positionnement par rapport aux produits
de l'avenir donc et les nouvelles
technologies vont arriver comment les
technologies changent nos vies
voilà présenté un peu tous ces produits
ça m'intéresse énormément qu'est ce qui
m'intéresse aussi énormément c'est de
voir comment la france peut se
positionner au milieu de tout ça et au
niveau de ces startups et quels sont les
produits innovants les produits français
vont pouvoir changer nos vies et
probablement aussi influent nos
comportements demain et donc dans ce
cadre là j'ai une playlist qui s'appelle
take made in france sur laquelle je
présente les startups innovantes
french tech et notamment sa qui était
présente au csa à las vegas alors oublié
au fur et à mesure parce que j'ai
énormément de contenu à vous publiez
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui me
tient énormément à coeur et je trouve
que sur youtube
d'une manière générale c'est très très
peu représentées et c'est vraiment
dommage
donc je m'en fais un petit peu l'écho au
travers de la chaîne youtube c'est très
heureux de pouvoir rencontrer la french
tech à l'ifa à berlin en septembre de
l'année dernière
aujourd'hui maxime est ce que tu peux
parler de la french siècle on est sur le
salon l'ifa ont bien précisé à berlin
c'était aussi aux rencontres
internationales de la french touch
il ya aussi quelques bons mois
[Musique]
j'étais au bhv maré pour rencontrer des
start up qui allait partir au cs bonjour
à tous aujourd'hui on est avec stéphane
qui a une solution ou rendre vos enfants
pour faire de vous entendre du super g t
au cs rencontrer toutes ces startups
[Musique]
oh
mais surtout
trois séances la prudence est sûre le
récap art c'est juste la zone où yann et
les petites startups innovantes
donc c'est la deuxième délégation néo
jusqu'à les américains alors je me suis
fait pas mal et j'étais très très très
heureux super on aurait pouvoir en
parler avec emmanuel macron au président
de la république parce que radio général
un président en fonction pouvoir le
chopper et lui parler de ça entre deux
portes c'est pas très facile et je vais
pas dire pas donné à tout le monde mais
voilà que vraiment le moment réussir à
se croiser dans un contexte très très
très particulier et je suis super
heureux parce que j'ai réussi à avoir ce
petit moment là pour pouvoir discuter
très rapidement trop rapidement mais bon
voilà
il a non pas du temps chargé moi aussi
et surtout lui donc voila nous était
très très très heureux de ça justement
mais je voulais en parler avec vous
parce que c'est vraiment une anecdote de
dengue et ça n'arrive pas souvent
alors c'est vrai que le crs ça a été des
rencontres de coupe j'ai rencontré
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs se rencontrer
beaucoup de monde se rencontre aussi
youtuber américaine que j'adore à justin
j'ai eu la chance de croiser sylvie
brender stevie wonder mon idole de
toujours cette ville
là
depuis le début l'année 2018 il se passe
que des chose de dingue je pense que ça
va continuer parce que va y avoir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui
vont s'enchaîner beaucoup de surprises
j'ai encore pas mal de déplacés pas mal
bouger donc je vous invite à rester
connectés
je pense qu'on va vivre des situations
incroyables
je vous remercie beaucoup d'être là je
vous invite à mes cd jolie pousse à vous
abonner à rester connectés
parce que comme je vous le dis on va
parler toujours plus toujours mieux de
high tech de high tech en règle générale
mais aussi des startups françaises
innovantes et voir un petit peu ce que
la france a dans le ventre
au niveau de ces startups tech merci à
vous je vous embrasse
à très bientôt portez vous bien ça
[Musique]